it's interesting to talk about the
process of writing you mentioned you
were in new york
what have you learned from writing these
two books about the actual process of
writing
and maybe i don't know what's the most
interesting thing to talk about there
may be the biggest challenges
or the boring mundane systematic like
day-to-day of what worked for you
like hacks or or even just about the
neuroscience
that you've learned through the process
of trying to write them
here's the thing i learned if you think
that it's going to take you a year to
write your book it's going to take you
three years to write your book
that's the first thing i learned is that
you
no matter how organized you are
it's always going to take way longer
than what you think um in part because
um very few people make an outline and
then just stick to it
you know the the some of the topics
really take on a life of their own and
to some extent you want to let them
get you want to let them have their
voice you know you want to follow
leads until you feel satisfied that
you've dealt with the topic
um uh appropriately
but i and that part is actually fun it's
not fun to feel like you're
constantly behind the eight ball in
terms of time yeah
um but it is the exploration and the
foraging for information is incredibly
fun
for me anyways i found it really
enjoyable and if i wasn't also running a
lab at the same time and trying to
keep my family going uh you know it
would have been
the whole thing would have just been fun
um but
i would say the hardest thing about the
most important thing i think i learned
is also the hardest thing and not it for
me which is
um knowing what to leave out
a really good storyteller knows what to
leave out
in in academic writing you
you shouldn't leave anything out you all
the details should be there
and um and
i you know i've written
or participated in in writing
over 200 papers peer-reviewed paper so
i'm pretty good with detail knowing what
to leave out
knowing what to leave out and not
harming the validity of the story
that is a tricky tricky thing it was
tricky when i wrote how emotions are
made but that's a standard
popular science book so it's 300
something pages and then you know
it has like a thousand endnotes and then
each of the endnotes is attached to a
web note which is also long
so i mean you know it's um
and it start and i mean the final draft
i wrote
three drafts of that book actually and
the final draft and then i had to cut by
uh third i mean or i mean i you know it
was like a hundred and
fifty thousand words or something and i
had to cut it down to like 110.
so um obviously it's i struggle with
what to leave out you know brevity is
not my strong suit i'm always telling
people that it's a warning
so that's why this book was a i you know
i'd always been really fascinated with
essays i
i love reading essays and after reading
a a small set of essays by anne fatiman
um called at large and at small which i
just loved these little essays
was what's the topic of those essays
they are they're called
um familiar essays so they're the topics
are
like everyday topics like mail
um coffee chocolate i mean just like
and what she does is she weaves her own
experience
it's a little bit like these
conversations that you're so good at
curating actually
um you're weaving together history and
philosophy and science and also personal
reflections and
a little bit you feel like you're like
eavesdropping on someone's train of
thought in a way
it's really they're really compelling to
me and
even if it's just like a mundane topic
yeah but it's so interesting
to um learn about
like all of these little stories
in the in the wrapping of the history of
like
mail like that's in that's really
interesting and so
i read these essays and then i wrote to
her a little fan girl
email um this was many years ago and um
and i said i i i just loved you i loved
this book and how did you learn to write
essays like this
and she gave me a reading list of essays
that i should read like
writers and so i read them all and
anyway so
i decided it would be a really good
challenge for me
to try to write something really brief
where i could
focus on you know one or two
really fascinating tidbits of
neuroscience
connect it to connect each one to
something philosophical or
you know like just a question about
human nature do it in a really brief
format
without violating
the validity of the science
that was a i just set myself this would
i thought of as a really really big
challenge in part because it was an
incredibly hard thing for me to do in
the first book
yeah we should say that this is uh the
seven and a half lessons is a very short
book
i mean it's uh it's like it embodies
uh brevity right the whole point
throughout is
just i mean you could tell that there's
editing
like there's pain in trying to bring
it as brief as possible as clean as
possible
yeah yeah so it's i the way i think of
it is um
you know it's a little book of big
science and big ideas yeah really big
ideas and and
in brief little packages and um you know
i wrote it
um so that people could read it i love
reading on the beach
i love reading essays on the beach i
read it i wrote it so people could read
it on the beach or in the bathtub
or you know a subway stop even if the
beach is frozen over
in the snow yeah so my husband dan calls
it the first neuroscience beach read
that's his um that's his phrasing yeah
and like like you said you learned a lot
about writing from your husband like you
were saying offline
well he's he is of the two of us he
is the better writer he is a masterful
writer
um he um he's also i mean
he you know he's a phd in computer
science he's he's a software engineer
but he's
he's also really good at
uh organization of knowledge so he built
for
a company he used to work for he built
one of the first knowledge management
systems
and he's he now works at google where he
does
engineering education like he's he
understands how to tell
a good story uh just
you know about anything really um he's
got impeccable timing he's really funny
and luckily for me he knows very little
about psychology or neuroscience
well now he knows more obviously but so
you know he was really when how emotions
were made
um you know he was really really helpful
to me because
um the first draft of every chapter was
me talking to him about what
on you know i would talk out loud about
what i wanted to say
and the order in which i wanted to say
it and then i would write it
and then he would read it and um tell me
all the bits that could be excised
yeah and sometimes we would you know i
should say i mean we don't he and i
don't
really argue about much except um
directions in the car like that's where
that's if we're going to have an
argument that's going to be where it's
going to happen where
what's the what's the nature of the
argument about directions exactly
i don't really know it's just that we're
very i think it's that
spatially you know he he um
i use egocentric space so i want to say
you know
turn left like i was i'm i'm reasoning
in relation to like my own physical
corporeal body so you know you walk to
the church and you turn left and you
then you know whatever you know i'm
always like and his you know he gives
directions
um allocentrically which means um
organized around north south east west
right
so to you the the earth is at the center
of the solar system and to him
no i'm not reasonably i'm at the center
you're at the center of the solar system
okay so uh anyway so we but but here
we you know we we had some really
rip-roaring arguments like
really rip-roaring arguments where he
would say like who is this for
is this for the one percent can i be
like one percent meaning
not you know not wealth but like
civilians versus academics you know so
are these for the scientists or for the
is this for the civilians right so he
speaks for the for the people for the
civilians for the people and i'd be like
no you have to and so he made you know
after one
terrible argument that we had where it
was really starting to affect our our
relationship because we were so mad at
each other all the time
um he made these little signs writing
and science and we only use them this
this was like
when you when you pulled out a sign
that's it like the other person just
wins and you have to stop fighting about
it yeah
and that's it great and so we just did
that um
and we didn't really have to use it too
much for this book because this book was
in some ways um uh
you know i didn't have to learn a lot of
new things for this book i had to learn
some but i
a lot of um what i
learned for seven and uh for um how
emotions are made
really st stood me in good stead for for
this book so there was a little bit each
essay was a little bit of learning
a couple were was a little more than
than a small amount but
um but i i didn't have so much trouble
here um
i had a lot of trouble with the first
book um but still even here
you know um you know he would tell me
that i could take something out and i
really wanted to keep it
and i think we only use the signs once
you